>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> JOHN COLE: Well,
good afternoon everyone.
Welcome to the Library of Congress.
I'm John Cole.
Up until this week, I was the
Director of the Center for the Book
in the Library of Congress, which
indeed is sponsoring this talk.
But through different
sets of circumstances,
which pleased me very much,
I've started a new position,
which is a historian of
the Library of Congress.
And I'm going to be
developing a new history office
about the library, for the library.
But I'm exercising my prerogative as
the founding Director of the Center
for the Book by not only
introducing our speaker today,
but also on Thursday we
have a second talk related
to elections and the year.
And I will be coming back to do some
of those introductions as we move
into a new phase in the history
of the Center for the Book.
The Center was created
by Daniel Boorstin
when he was Librarian
of Congress in 1977.
And he plucked me out of the ranks
to become the founding director,
because largely of my interest
in, he knew of my interest
in the history of the library.
And here we are all of these
years later still having a chance
to show my interest
and to keep learning
about the Library of Congress.
Dr. Boorsin's idea was that we,
the library should do more to reach
out to the general public to
promote books and reading.
And as the Center for the Book
has grown, we have done so,
but we've added literacy promotion,
we've added library promotion.
The center was created
as a partnership
between the private sector.
We were started with
donations from publishers.
McGraw Hill actually
and Time Life Books.
And continued to really
support most of our activities
by private donations,
often related to projects.
But the Library of Congress supports
our positions, and as we have grown,
we have also created the first,
well Young Readers Center.
It's the first part of the
library that's open to the interest
and programming for 16 and under.
And it is in the of Jefferson
Building the Library of Congress.
We also are closely associated
with the National Book Festival,
which came to the Library of
Congress with Laura Bush in 2001,
and we just celebrated our
15th annual Festival last year.
And I can announcement this
year's festival is September 24th.
It is now moved off the mall, into
the Washington Convention Center.
And it's bigger and
better than ever.
And in addition, has toilets
and air conditioner inside.
So, and actually the programming
opportunities are much greater too,
as you can well imagine.
You've joined us for a
Books and Beyond Program.
Thank you.
The Books and Beyond
Series started in 1996.
And the notion was to have author
talks about books that were related
to the Library of Congress,
one way or another.
Often as is the case today,
and often is the case,
the author has made good use of the
Library of Congress's resources.
But we also look for books
that have other kinds
of relationships to the library.
For example, they were
published by the library,
which obviously will be
related to our collections.
Or maybe they are a
result of a special project
from the Library of Congress.
But since 1996, we're
approaching 400 of these talks.
One of the nice features
about them is that the Library
of Congress films them
for its website.
As we actually film the
author presentations
for the National Book Festival.
But in the Books and
Beyond Series, we now are,
as I said, approaching 400.
And of those, around 300
of them have been filmed.
We didn't get started quite when
we should have with the filming.
But all of the talks including
today's talk are films.
So I ask you to kindly turn
off all things electronic.
We will hear from our speaker.
Then we will have a
question and answer period.
And then finally, there'll be a
book signing at about 1 o'clock.
It needs to start by
1 o'clock for certain.
As you know, our talk today
is "The Fight to Vote."
And it's by Michael
Waldman, who is here to talk
about the book and to sign it.
Michael is a constitutional
lawyer and an expert
on the presidency and
American democracy.
And he too has the right Job.
Since 2005, he has been President
of the Brennan Center for Justice
at the New York University
School of Law.
A nonpartisan law and policy
institute that focuses
on improving the systems houses
for a purpose and a goal,
and focuses on improving the
systems of democracy and justice.
And I learned today the Brennan
Center also has an office
in Washington and there
is some literature
out on our literature tables
where you also will find out more
about the Center for the Book
and our future programs during
the book signing period.
Under Michael's leadership,
the Brennan Center has become a
leading legal voice on election law,
constitutional law, government
reform and racial justice.
Two years ago he tackled the
tough constitutional issue
of the Second Amendment.
And he chronicled his
discoveries and made his analysis
in a widely reviewed
and praised book
"The Second Amendment a Biography."
And we were privileged to have
him speak here of the Center
for the Book at the Library
of Congress all almost
2 years ago to the day.
It was on June 24, 2014.
Now, nearly 2 days to the day
later, we are lucky to have him here
to discuss his new book, "The Fight
to Vote," which is an analysis
of the crucial American struggle,
very much on our minds today.
And I think I mentioned
we have a talk
on the history of American
elections.
Not elections as much as
the presidential power
and the presidencies and the
families related to the presidency
on Thursday when Stephen
Hess will be here.
But today we're going to be
able to hear Michael talk
about his second book
that we've featured.
And it too is really
getting excellent reviews.
And we're very pleased
that he can be here to talk
about "The Fight to Vote."
It's so important in
our democracy right now,
and certainly on our
minds right now,
what really constitutes the
definition of the consent
of the governed, and how the right
to vote is a crucial part of it.
So please join me in
welcoming Michael Waldman.
[ Applause ]
Michael, thank you.
>> MICHAEL WALDMAN: Thank you.
Thank you John for the introduction
and thank you for all you have done
for the book and for our
democracy by making so many
of the ideas available
and by lifting up the idea
of us coming together
as a national community
around these discussions
and debates.
Thank you to the library
of Congress.
I want to acknowledge and thank
my friend Raf Sagalen [assumed
spelling], who is the agent
for me and for so many
of the great authors whose work
is in the walls of this building.
And my colleagues from
the Brennan Center.
It is a challenging and exciting
time to work on these issues.
I appreciate all of you
coming today also at a time
of great sorrow for our country.
It is striking to walk from Union
Station to here seeing the flags
at half-mast and understanding
that the country at a moment
like this can come together
with the militant rededication
to the ideals we all share together.
This book tells part of
the story of those ideals.
And how we forge them and how
we try to live up to them,
and how hard it often can be.
I am asked all the time why
did I write this book now.
And actually the first question
I'm often asked these days is
so do you still support
the right to vote.
And I generally answer yes.
But even before this topsy-turvy
election, this was a period
where the institutions of American
democracy, the institutions
of our electoral system
have been under pressure
and facing strains they have
not felt in years and years.
This is going to be an election
where in 17 states new
voting laws are on the books.
For the first time in a
high turnout election laws
that I believe actually make it
harder for many Americans to vote.
It's the first time
in half a century
that we have a presidential
election without the full protection
of the Voting Rights Act of 1965,
which was weakened greatly
by the Supreme Court.
It's the first presidential
election where the full force
of citizens united, and other recent
Supreme Court rulings on money
and politics are being
felt throughout our system.
And it is a not uncomplicated
story, but here's just an example
of the kind of impact we are seeing.
In the last election, 2014 election
the top 100 donors, federal donors,
gave more than the 4.75
million small donors combined.
That is a level of concentrated
political wealth we haven't seen
since the Gilded Age
in the United States.
Add all this on top of the
ongoing normal problems
of our electoral system,
partisan gerrymandering,
ramshackle voter registration, and
election administration systems,
and voting machines,
and all the other things
that people know about it.
And it is not a surprise that voter
turnout in the last election plunged
to the lowest level in 72 years.
And that was that was
during the World War II,
when a lot of Americans were
overseas fighting and so
in a sense they had an excuse.
These are signs of strain
and stress on our democracy,
on the meaning of that
right to vote.
And so what I wanted to understand
for myself, for my colleagues
and for our readers was
why is this happening now?
Is it unusual?
And what turns out to be the case,
when you look back at the long sweep
of history is that the
strains we're facing now,
the fights we're having now, the
fact that the right to vote seems
to require a fight to vote.
That is consequential.
These debates are fierce.
They are challenging,
but they are not new.
In fact, this question of the fight
to vote has been at the center
of American history,
from the very beginning.
It's been at the heart
of political debates.
It's often been a fulcrum
for elections.
It's a fight that has been
raw and rowdy, and often very,
very partisan from the beginning.
And just as we might see
now, throughout history
as many Americans have demanded
their place at the table
and have claimed their
voice in our democracy,
many others have fought
just as hard to stop them,
to restrict that right to vote.
And so that is ultimately
the context,
the usable history I
was seeking to find
in understanding today's
moment, today's fights.
And as I say, this goes back
all the way to the beginning.
This is not a fight
that started last year,
or 50 years ago in Selma, Alabama.
It's been going on for
240 years, at least.
At the time the nation was
founded, as we all know,
it was far from anything any of
us would consider a democracy.
The book begins fittingly, as
we sit in the Jefferson Building
in the Madison Building across
from the Jefferson Building,
the book begins actually with
Thomas Jefferson sitting at his desk
in Philadelphia writing the preamble
to the Declaration of Independence.
And stating in that famous preamble
the government is legitimate only
if it rests on the
consent of the governed.
And that was a radical
idea then, as well as now.
And it had a tremendous
force, a tremendous power,
and obviously was not the
reality at that moment.
Among other things, as I note,
Jefferson while he was writing
that was attended to by a
14-year-old slave boy, Bob Hemmings,
Sally Hemmings' younger brother.
But the idea took on
a life of its own.
And one of the things that was
interesting is we all know,
we remember from school
perhaps, that at that time
when we were not a
democracy, only white men
who owned property
were allowed to vote.
That was the tradition
in effect handed
down from England in the continent.
But even then it was controversial.
The power of those revolutionary
ideals began to crack the certainty
that surrounded that approach
in 1776 in Pennsylvania,
Benjamin Franklin led a
working man's revolt in one
of the only places in
the whole revolution
where it really looked like,
you know the French Revolution.
Where a giant throng of people
stormed the State House.
He led a working man's revolt,
demanding a new government,
and demanding as its key element
that the property requirement
for voting be ended.
He actually was the
president of the convention
that wrote the Constitution
of Pennsylvania.
It was the world's most radical
Constitution at the time.
And he said, this is how
he explained it, he said,
'There's a man who owns a jackass,
and it's worth $50,
so the man can vote.
Then the jackass dies.
The man is older.
He understands more
about government,
but the jackass is still dead.
So the man cannot vote.
So therefore,' he asked, 'who
really has the right to vote?
The man or the jackass.'
This seemed pretty
persuasive in Pennsylvania
and they created the most democratic
constitution the world had
ever seen.
Up in Massachusetts, John Adams
reflected the other strain.
He was aghast at this notion
of expanding the right to vote,
of expanding American democracy.
He wrote their Constitution, he
was urged to do the same thing,
to end the property requirement.
And he wrote, he said,
'If you do that, he said,
women will demand the right to vote.
Lads of 18 will think their
interests insufficiently attended to
and they will demand
the right to vote.
And men,' he said, '
who have not a farthing
to their name will think
themselves worthy of an equal voice
in government and then will
demand the right to vote.'
Adam said, 'there will
be no end of it.'
And that's basically the book.
That's basically the
story of what happened
over the next 2.5 centuries.
The idea that government rested
on the consent of the governed,
and that the vote was the center
of that consent took
on a life of its own.
And it's worth noting in
this wonderful building,
named after James Madison.
As you know, Madison's notes
are our principle basis
for understanding what
the conversations were
at the constitutional convention.
And the Constitution
does not originally refer
to a right to a right to vote.
There was even a move to put
that property requirement
into the Constitution,
which Madison shrugged off.
He didn't think it was such a bad
idea, but he did it was a good idea.
And Franklin actually
blocked it with his prestige.
We only know those notes
because they were released
many decades later.
But when the doors opened
up and it came time to fight
for the ratification
of the Constitution,
in that very controversial
debate where the antifederalists,
as they were called,
made a very strong case
against the Constitution.
One of the issues was this question
of whether it was a counter
revolution, whether it was elitist,
whether the ordinary people
would be cut out, and Madison
and the other founders, even the
ones who didn't believe it went
to the country and said no
this is about democracy.
In Federalist 57, Madison
asked the question.
He said, 'Who are to be the
electors of the new government?
Not the rich more than the poor.
Not the learned more
than the ignorant.
Not the haughty heirs of famous
names more than the humble sons
of obscurity and unpropitious
fortune.
The great body of the people
are to be the electors."
That's as compelling a definition of
democracy as we could find even now.
And again, that took
on a life of its own.
In the 1820s and the 1830s, was
the first great breakthrough
for this expanded right to vote.
And in the modern political context,
it's worth noting it was won
by angry, white, working-class
men of the time.
The period of Jacksonian Democracy.
When states all across
the country ended
that property for white
men in voting.
And one of the interesting
and for me,
slightly unexpected storylines
throughout all of this,
is that that victory for
voting rights was not won
by voting rights groups, or a
lawsuit, or citizen activists.
It was waged and won by
political parties, by politicians,
by cynical insiders often.
One of the great leaders in
that fight was Martin Van Buren,
who was the governor of New
York and then President.
And Van Buren helped to found the
world's first mass political party,
the Democratic Party,
as we now call it.
Around this issue of wider suffrage.
And he was no firebrand.
There's a story from the time that
the Albany was notoriously corrupt,
even then as a state capital, and
one state senator bet another.
He said I bet you I
can get Van Buren
to give a straight answer
to a simple question.
And the other guy took the bet.
And he went up to Van Buren and
said, Mr. Van Buren, tell me,
is it true that the
sun rises in the east?
And Van Buren said well, seeing
as how I never wake up that early,
I cannot speak to that
from personal experience,
so I don't know the answer to that.
He led the fight to
expand voting rights.
And this role of insiders, the role
politicians and political parties,
is a significant storyline
throughout this
that recurs and often surprises.
The next great breakthrough
of course,
albeit one that was
tragically cut short,
came during and after the Civil War.
Because the expansion of the
vote to working-class white men,
the idea that we were democracy.
The almost faddish devotion to
political participation that you saw
around the country,
again set up the demand
for the next great breakthrough.
At the end of the Civil War, as the
book describes, Frederick Douglass
and the other abolitionists realized
that the next great fight was
to enfranchise the former slaves.
To extend the right
to vote to black men.
And Lincoln, Abraham Lincoln was
opposed to extending the right
to vote to the former slaves.
He was ardently against it.
He campaigned against it.
But on this, as on so many other
issues, the war changed Lincoln.
By the end of the war, 1 out of
10 Union soldiers was a black man.
When Lincoln, just
a few hundred yards
from here gave his famous
second inaugural address,
back when the inaugurals were
on this side of the capital,
half the audience were
African-American men
and women, many of them in uniform.
And 3 days after Appomattox,
3 days after the surrender
by Robert E. Lee, Lincoln
gave his first major speech
on reconstruction.
On what he wanted to have
happen after the Civil War.
It was a long speech and he gave
it to from the second floor window
of the White House by candlelight.
And in the middle of the speech he
said, 'Now I've been criticized,
because his original plans
for reconstruction did
not extend voting rights.
And he said, 'I've been criticized
for not extending the right to vote.
And I now agree with that criticism.
In fact, I think that there should
be the right to vote for those
who have served in the military,
for those who are intelligent.'
He went through some categories.
And actually in the cabinet
meeting a few days later,
he made clear to his cabinet that
he was likely to go the whole way.
At least one member of the
audience, historians tell us,
caught the significance
of what Lincoln said.
John Wilkes Booth was there.
And when Lincoln said this, Booth
gasped that means citizenship.
That is the last speech
he will ever give.
And he in fact tried to
get the guy at that moment
to shoot Lincoln on the spot.
The guy standing next to him.
And when he wouldn't
do it, Booth said,
'Well then by God I
will put him through.
And two days later, went to
Ford's Theater and did that.
This was the case that,
I'm not meaning to imply
that Booth was a big
Lincoln fan other than that.
His previous idea had been to you
know kidnap him and bring him south.
But the spark for the
assassination, we are told was
in fact Lincoln's conversion
to the cause of voting rights.
And this was, as it turns out
one of the great central fights.
One of the great central
issues in reconstruction.
And again, one where
partisanship plays a significant,
positive role in expanding
the right to vote.
This time it was the
Republican Party,
which pushed through the 15th
amendment to the Constitution,
which prohibited discrimination.
Which said the right to vote could
not be abridged because of race.
And it's important to note, as I
said, this is a partisan issue.
The identity of which party is
pushing for greater voting rights,
and which party is pushing against
voting rights, often changes.
Often switches.
It's not always one
party or another.
In this case it was the republicans.
They did this out of a mix of
idealism and political calculus,
to help win the black
vote in the border states.
But, it's also worth noting that, I
mentioned that the phrase the right
to vote, the notion of a right to
vote was not in the Constitution.
And you'll hear people
say that all the time.
That it's not in the Constitution.
There's no right to vote.
Well it wasn't in the
original Constitution.
But starting with the
15th amendment,
and actually the 14th
amendment before that.
It has been added
to the Constitution 5
separate times, explicitly.
There is a right to vote
in the Constitution.
It's in there more than
just about any other topic.
But it was added after
the original Constitution.
And this was one of the
most significant times.
And what many Americans for
a long time did not realize,
and we now all understand is that
there was a flowering of democracy
in the south after
the 15th amendment.
Voter participation rates among
African-American men reached 90%.
Hundreds were elected to state
legislatures, to Congress,
to governorships, even
to the U.S. Senate.
And then as we know, it was
cruelly, effectively revoked.
First, by terrorism.
By the Ku Klux Klan and
other paramilitary groups,
which were serving in effect
as a military wing of
the Democratic Party.
This is not, we all
understand the perils
of living in an age of terrorism.
This was, we are not
living in either the first,
or the greatest age of
terrorism in the United States.
That was after the Civil War.
The violence drove many
people away from the polls.
And then cowardice, and
a cynical deal struck
out to settle the 1876
presidential election
that saw the troops
withdrawn from the south.
And effectively ended
for a century or so,
the national government's effort
to protect the right to vote
for the former slaves
and their descendants.
And one of things that
was interesting is
that it didn't happen right away.
Voter turnout rates among black
men was actually quite high
in the south for decades after that.
It wasn't until the Jim Crow
Constitution of the 1890s,
which formally, and creatively
and systematically
disenfranchise black voters.
That it was completely done.
And as many of you know, that
central fact what was called
in those days the solid south.
The all-white Democratic
Party south,
with very low voter
participation rates
of any kind was the
central political fact
in American government
for decades and decades.
Well into the 20th
century, into my lifetime.
What a lot of people don't
know, is that during this period
in the late 19th century, something
similar happened in the north,
not as bad, but something similar.
The cities of the North during this
time were filled with immigrants.
They weren't immigrants from Mexico.
They were from Ireland, and
Italy, and Russia, and Poland,
and other European countries.
And a lot of the established
institutions,
a lot of the blue bloods of
the time reacted with language
that would be very
familiar to us today.
And in fact, many of them
decided that this idea
of universal voting rights wasn't
such a good idea after all.
John Adams' great grandson said
that if you have universal suffrage,
you will have government of
corruption and vice dominated,
as he said by the Celtic
proletariat in the North,
the African proletariat
in the South,
the Chinese proletariat in the West.
So it turned out that voting rights
wasn't such a good idea after all.
Two of my favorite
surprises during that period,
one of the great leaders of
the opposition to the right
to vote was E.L. Godkin, who
founded the "Nation Magazine"
and Walt Whitman, wrote ardently
against democracy at this point,
and against the right to
vote for the same reasons.
And what you saw throughout
the north were a series of laws
and a series of practices.
Some of them quite
defensible on their face,
that effectively made it much
harder for working people,
for non-English speakers,
for non-educated people,
for poor people to vote.
Everything from voter
registration, which was a new thing,
imposed in many places only in
democratic and Catholic big cities
and not in republican and rural
areas out in the countryside.
Even something like
the printed ballot
which means you have
to be able to read it.
Or the secret ballot, which
meant that similarly that you had
to process who you were
voting for on your own.
Things that we obviously think are
important parts of what it means
to run a clean and honest democracy.
Always these various things
made it harder, and harder,
and harder the other
crackdowns on the often corrupt,
but highly participatory
political parties of the time meant
that voter turnout rates began to
really plummet in the late 1800s.
And then you added on top of that a
new factor, which began at that time
and which of course we're living
with now, which is the role
of big money in American politics.
Which had not been a
factor until the late 1800s.
But now with the tremendous
inequality of that Gilded Age time,
the campaign money from the robber
barons began to dominate politics
at the very moment that the
vote was being pushed back.
So in many ways, American democracy
slid backwards in the late 1800s.
And it's an important lesson.
Because we think of the
beginning, where we were,
had a kernel of the democratic idea,
but that we've expanded
it over time.
And that's true and it's
true as Dr. King said talking
about voting rights that the
moral arc of the universe is long,
but it bends toward justice.
But it sometimes goes backwards.
Then what happened after that period
in the late 19th century is
something else that also happens
with some recurring frequency,
which is there was a response.
There was a period of
reform and renewal.
Very significantly in
response to what had happened.
Now we know it of course,
as the Progressive Era.
And when we learn about the
Progressive Era and we think
about it, it's certainly the
case that it was in a lot
of respects very similar to our time
in terms of the public's concerns.
People were unsettled
by economic change.
They were unsettled by the new
degree of inequality that had come
into the American economy.
They were unnerved by
demographic change, by immigration.
They felt that the
political system was rigged.
They felt that government was not
functional, that it was not working,
given the challenges of that time.
And we think about the Progressive
Era as being when the beginnings
of the modern governmental
system was built,
you know food safety
regulation, or antitrust laws.
And that's all true, but to
the Progressives of the time,
they felt that restoring and
revitalizing the institutions
of American democracy, and
expanding the vote were critical
to their efforts.
They passed the first
campaign finance laws,
some of which were
affected by Citizens United.
They passed the 17th
amendment to the Constitution,
which to them was a central
campaign finance reform effort.
That was the moment that gave
the right to vote to people
for senators, previously it
had been state legislatures
who elected senators.
And they felt that the state
legislatures were corrupt
and were dominated by big special
interests and that giving that vote
to a much wider group
would change that.
And by the way when you hear today,
some people actually urge the
revocation of the 17th amendment.
Saying that it was a power grab by
Washington imposed on the states.
It's actually the other way around.
The U.S. Senate was the
last place that wanted
to do the 17th amendment.
It was actually demanded
by the states and by people
of the states at the time.
And we know that they expanded
direct democracy, referenda,
and a whole host of other ways
that this vote gained more power.
And they took the single, in numeric
terms, the single biggest step
to expand the vote, which
is the 19th amendment,
guaranteeing the right
to vote to women.
And we sort of skip
over this one often
in our thinking of
American democracy.
We know it happened.
But it turns out that the
fight for the vote for women,
for that 19th amendment, was
every bit as fiercely contested,
as dramatic, as any voting
rights fight before or since.
And there are many stories that
we learned for the first time.
Those of us at the Brenna Center,
we work on this stuff day and night.
You know, we know and
Secretary Clinton mentioned this
in her speech the other
day that in 1848
at Seneca Falls was the first time
that the demand for a right to vote
for women was really put forward
by the Seneca Falls Declaration.
The fact is not a whole lot
happened after that, for decades
and decades not a whole
lot happened after that.
And it was not until 1911, when a
small group of very young women,
many of them had been in
graduate school in England,
where they participated in
the suffrage movement there.
Came back to the United States and
in the face of kind of eye rolling
by their elders said
that they were going
to try something really audacious.
There were going to actually try
to pass a constitutional amendment
to give women the right to vote.
Just 3 months later, the day before
his inauguration as president,
Woodrow Wilson got off the
train a few blocks from here,
and was expecting to be
greeted by a giant throng.
And there was basically
nobody there.
It was the Princeton Glee
Club and that was it.
They belted out a song, and
"The New York Times" wrote,
they made up in enthusiasm
what they lacked in numbers.
They were very pro-democrat
even then.
And finally Wilson's aide
said, where are all the people?
And the hosts said with
sort of embarrassment, well,
they're actually all down
Pennsylvania Avenue where there was,
for the very first time, a
march for women's suffrage
down Pennsylvania Avenue the day
before the presidential inaugural,
5000 women marching
for the right to vote.
At the head of the parade was a
27-year-old woman on a white horse,
named Inez Milholland,
dressed in the costume
of a Greek goddess
carrying a banner,
sort of a hallucinatory figuring.
And we're especially fond of her,
because she was a recent graduate
of NYU School of Law, where
the Brannan Center is.
And 5000 women.
And on either side a
hundred thousand men flanking
Pennsylvania Avenue.
They were there for the inaugural.
Many of them were drunk.
And they started spitting
and throwing things.
They broke through the lines
and assaulted the women.
Beat them up.
Sent 100 women to the hospital.
They had to fight their way
down Pennsylvania Avenue
to the Treasury Department,
where the march ended.
And it was a very big deal.
It was massively publicized.
The publicity you know, overshadow
the inauguration in many ways.
The police chief of
Washington DC had to resign.
And public opinion swung in
support of voting rights for women.
And when I learned this story,
I thought and perhaps some
of you are having the same thought.
That sounds just like Selma.
That this public publicized
attack on nonviolent protesters
for the right to vote,
revealing the injustice of it,
the changing broader public opinion.
It was 50 years before Selma.
And it took 5 more years.
And a pioneering use of
strategies and tactics of protest
that really began with the suffrage
movement in the United States.
Everything from hunger strikes.
They picketed the White House
for two years, straight.
They ran political candidates
against Woodrow Wilson
in states where they could.
A whole host of things.
All this before Gandhi used a
lot of these tactics in India.
Certainly before the
sit down strikes
and the American Labor
Movement in the '30s.
And obviously before the
civil rights movements
of the '50s and '60s.
And finally, in 1920,
won the right to vote.
And the electorate, the size
of the electorate doubled
in one fell swoop.
It was an extraordinary
breakthrough.
Much of the 20th century, there was
this continued inexorable pressure,
but there were a lot
of ongoing problems
that built up, and built up.
And the true ultimate breakthrough,
which I won't go into much detail
about because it's something
you know the most about,
came with the Voting Rights Act of
1965 when for the very first time,
really, we as a country,
articulated the expectation
that every eligible citizen
would be able to vote.
And it as accompanied at the time
by a constitutional
amendment ending the poll tax.
By another constitutional amendment
lowering the voting age to 18.
All I will say in terms of
the Voting Rights Act is
that it too was the
product of political forces
that were complex, and intense.
And obviously the principle movers
of that voting rights act were the
ordinary people who braved violence
and even death in Selma,
Alabama during the great voting
rights struggle and march there.
But it's also the case
that it was the product
of this incredibly fascinating duel,
joust between these two viscerally
talented southern political leaders.
Dr. Martin Luther King
and Lyndon Johnson.
And you know this is one of the
questions that arose after the movie
"Selma" was did Johnson, you
know did he get a fair treatment
in that movie.
And I certainly came out of the
research concluding no he did not.
Johnson was most of the time
strongly for and extremely important
in the fight for voting rights.
But King and Johnson pushed
and pulled with each other.
And so much of their
interaction was taped.
And so you can hear these
incredible conversations.
Three days before Bloody
Sunday, the Friday before,
King came to the White
House and met with Johnson.
And Johnson did not tell
King, 'by the way Dr. King,
I've ordered the Justice Department
to draft the Voting Rights Act'
over the rejection of the
liberals who were there actually.
'I've ordered them to draft
it and we've negotiated it
with the Republicans
in the Senate already.'
And King did not tell Johnson,
'by the way Mr. President,
turn on your TV on Sunday,
we're marching in Selma.'
And the reaction of course,
to that public violence created a
spontaneous national mass movement
demanding action that enabled
Johnson, both pushed Johnson
and enabled him to then go before
the Congress a week later and give
that great speech where he said, 'we
shall overcome' embracing the slogan
of the civil rights movement.
And during this period, and after,
American democracy achieved a
formal openness, a formal equality
that it had never had before.
And when I was going up, when
I was learning this stuff,
that was sort of you
put your pencils down,
that was the status quo.
And that was the expectation.
It was expected that these
issues were a thing of the past
and that they weren't the subject
of intense current fighting.
Well, that is not how
it's turned out.
The last 15 years has seen,
once again as we see throughout
American history, tremendous focus
on these rules of democracy.
And I think a lot of
it actually started
with the recount in Florida in 2000.
Probably about 4 in the
morning that first night,
when people realized the country
was really closely divided,
that turnout now mattered a lot.
That you could win an election
by manipulating the system
or by turning your side out, or
by suppressing the other side.
And you began to see as a
strategy, building overtime,
a drive to restrict voting rights.
And this is where I get to
the contemporary part where,
I will note that as I said,
this is often a partisan fight.
It's often been the Democrats who
have been the side of restricting
or expanding the right to vote.
It's often been Republicans
were the most for,
for example woman's voting rights.
Who have been on the
side of expanding
or constricting the right to vote.
Right now in America today it
is the Conservative Movement,
and the Republican Party that
is pushing for these laws
to make it harder for
people to vote.
And the argument is made that this
is necessary to stop voter fraud.
As the only kind of voter fraud
that these laws really address would
be in-person voter impersonation.
Someone walking in and claiming
to be someone they're not.
And every bit of research will
tell you that that is less likely
that you are more likely to be hit
by lightning in the United States,
statistically than to commit
in-person voter impersonation.
Despite this concerted
strategic effort,
not a whole lot happened until 2011.
In 2011, a lot of state
legislatures changed hands.
And instantly you saw laws
being passed all over the place
to make it harder to vote.
Nineteen states passed 24 new
laws in a few months' time.
They ranged from harsh and
restricted new forms of voter ID,
to cutbacks in the early
voting, but especially
on the days used by
African-Americans.
To ending election day registration,
to crackdowns on voter
registration drives.
A whole host of things.
The Brennan Center, we played
a bit of a role in this,
in that this was happening
in public, obviously,
this was not a secret, it
was in state legislatures,
but the dots had not been connected.
And a year before, in October
2011, we put out a report.
We looked at all of
this stuff and concluded
that 5 million people might have
the right to vote restricted
or affected, or even lost.
And that helped kickoff
a big national debate.
It helped kickoff an awareness
on the part of a lot of people
that this was a political
strategy being carried out.
And so that when we and other voting
rights groups went to court in 2012,
the spring of 2012,
every single ones
of the worst new laws
was blocked, or bunted,
or postponed, or repealed.
And it didn't matter if
it was Republican judge
or a Democratic judge, or a
state judge, or a federal judge.
They understood that there was
something fundamental and sacred
in the right to vote that was
actually improperly being affected.
And that was kind of where it stood
until the Supreme Court
got involved.
Which is a much more divided and
much more frankly partisan court
than you find in most
other courthouses.
And as you may know, in
2013, the Supreme Court
in a case called Shelby County
versus Holder, struck down the heart
of the Voting Rights Act of 1965,
which everybody acknowledged was
the most successful civil rights law
in American history.
This was the part of the law that
required states with a history
of discrimination in voting to get
voting changes cleared in advanced
by the Justice Department
or a federal court.
And this was the ruling
during the arguments,
across the street, down the block.
This was the case where Justice
Scalia said in the courtroom
that he thought that the voting
rights act was nothing more than,
as he put it, a racial entitlement
which actually elicited
gasps in the courtroom.
He didn't write the opinion.
Chief Justice Roberts
wrote the opinion.
And he made a point
which has some validity.
He said you know,
voter participation rates among
African-Americans in many places,
including the South are now
higher than among white voters.
His main argument in effect
was that was then, this is now.
Therefore, it's not needed any more.
Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg wrote
a famous dissent in that case.
She said that that's like standing
in a rainstorm holding an umbrella
and not getting wet,
and deciding therefore
that you can throw
away the umbrella.
So who was right?
Who was right as a predicted
matter of what would happen?
Two hours after the
ruling came down,
The State of Texas
implemented its voter ID law,
and I should say I'm
actually for voter ID.
I'm not against voter ID, I think it
makes sense for people to have to be
who they say they are and it's not
crazy to ask t hem to prove it.
I'm against requiring forms of ID
that lots of people don't have.
Nationwide, around 11% of eligible
voters don't have a driver's license
or the other kind of
ID that's required.
In Texas, two hours later
the law was implemented,
it's the harshest law
in the country.
It's kind of notorious.
It's the one where you cannot
use your University of Texas ID
as a government ID, but you can use
your conceal to carry gun permit.
And the, now Stephen Colbert said,
well that's actually
very democratic.
It's a lot easier to get a
gun than a college education.
But he partisan intent
was fairly naked.
And at that precise moment, two
hours after the Supreme Court ruled,
608,000 registered voters in
Texas lost their right to vote.
Not potential, maybe
they'd vote someday.
Registered voters.
Disproportionately African-American.
Disproportionately Latino.
Disproportionately poor.
Disproportionately either
the elderly, or the young.
And one of those voters was a woman
who we met named Sandy Louise Bates.
We and others went to court on this.
And we met Sandy Louise Bates.
And she was born in Mississippi.
She remembered counting out money
for her grandmother
to pay the poll tax.
She moved to Detroit and Chicago.
Sort of the classic great migration.
She actually went to college.
She worked.
Then she retired, and she moved
to Texas, Round Rock, Texas,
where she lives on Social
Security and nothing else.
She's been voting since
she was 21 years old.
And she lost the right to vote.
And we asked her, why didn't you
just get your birth certificate
from Mississippi.
Why didn't you go through
the process
and get your birth
certificate from Mississippi?
And she said well that costs
$42 and I had to put those $42
where they would be the most good.
You can't eat a birth certificate.
And she was the lead
witness in the federal trial,
and with many others persuaded the
federal judge to strike down the law
as discriminatory, illegal,
violating the remaining parts
of the Voting Rights Act
and the Constitution.
That ruling was upheld by the most
conservative federal appeals court
in the country.
The Fifth Circuit.
And the law's still on the books.
It's still in effect.
It's going to be in
effect in November.
Because the simplified answer is
Texas is appealing very slowly.
And the wheels of justice
are grinding very slowly.
And ultimately this is not a fight
that will be won in the court
of law, but in the
court of public opinion.
And so we have every reason to
expect a lot of hand to hand combat
in courtrooms all over the country.
A lot of drives to make it
possible for people to vote.
We think that these new laws
will affect polling places,
certainly where we've
seen already evidence
that they cause long
lines and chaos.
And there's reason to be worried.
But there is also, I'll say in
conclusion reason for optimism.
Why would there be optimism,
other than temperament why
would there be optimism?
Just as perhaps we say in
the early 20th century,
this focus on the rules of
democracy, this recognition
that some people are trying to
take away others' right to vote.
This recognition that the system
needs to be changed if we want
to solve our problems, is creating
its own moment of pushback,
of renewal one hopes
of revitalization of
these institutions.
There's actually a tremendous
ferment going on on the issues
of democracy all over the country.
Plainly we see this in the
election, in both parties.
Where weather it's Bernie Sanders
saying he's winning these primaries
because of his position on campaign
finance, or Donald Trump saying
that he's the only one
who can't be bought.
Or Hillary Clinton
putting out what I regard
as by far the most robust set
of policy reform proposals
on this stuff, all though she
talks about it in a more muted way.
This issue is at the
center of debate again.
And you're seeing breakthroughs on
these issues all across the country.
The single biggest change that
could make a big difference
in our voting right now, would be
to change the way we register
voters in the United States.
If we move to automatic
voter registration.
Automatic and universal
registration,
which is how every
other democracy does it.
If we made it so that if
you're eligible to vote,
the government has the list, it's
responsible for keeping the list
and you stay on the list.
It would add 50 million
people to the rolls,
permanently, would cost less.
And for people who are worried about
fraud, it would address the accuracy
of the list, it would
clean up the lists
and it would make it
harder to abuse.
And the exciting thing
is it's starting
to happen all over the country.
In the last year and a half,
Oregon, California, West Virginia,
by bipartisan vote, Vermont,
by tri-partisan vote.
They've got the Democrats and
Republicans and the Socialists all
to vote for it, enacted automatic
voter registration for people
who interact with the DMV in those
states and they can broaden it
out to other agencies too.
We had a conference a couple
weeks ago and the State
of Connecticut came and announced
that the night before they
decided they were going to do it
without even waiting
for the legislature.
The Illinois legislature,
last week passed this.
While we don't know if Governor
Rauner is going to sign it,
there are enough votes
to override a veto.
We expect that if that happens, then
1 out of 5 voters will now be living
in states with automatic
registration.
We know from Oregon that it has
tripled the registration rates month
by month there.
It would be a tremendous
breakthrough
and it's happening
all over the country.
There are things like
that that are happening.
Creative new versions of
public financing being enacted
for campaign finance.
Redistricting reform, such
as redistricting commissions.
Being approved up by the
Supreme Court last year
and pushed in states.
Whether it was Ohio where
Governor Kasich backed it,
or California where
Governor Schwarzenegger,
or Florida where it
was liberal democrats
who pushed the redistricting reform.
It's sort of both parties
[inaudible]
and the reform is actually
genuinely bipartisan as a result.
There is a lot happening.
So that's really the question.
We are on the knife's edge.
We could be in a period
like the late 19th century.
The signs are there.
Where our democracy
slides backwards,
where participation
recedes, where the right
to vote takes on less meaning.
Or, as I hope and believe is
more likely to be the case,
we could be in a period, like
what followed, a time of renewal,
of activism on these issues,
that helps create a new
moment for American democracy.
Ultimately, even if this
happens it won't be over.
John Adams was right there
will be no end of it.
There will never be a point
where we're not fighting
over what it means
to have a democracy.
But the next chapter will
be written by all of us,
and those who come after, so.
[ Applause ]
I'm happy to take questions.
Raf.
>> I just think that
something simple can be
so consequential I just think it's
a really fascinating presentation.
Quick question.
Just say a minute about Whitman and
his objection, like what we know
about that I find to
be very interesting.
And secondly is [inaudible] can
you you know a little bit along the
subject, but can you say a little
bit about when a percentage of those
who voted [inaudible] is there
a connection between the temper
of the time, or candidates.
Are there some general guidelines
that you could draw form history?
>> MICHAEL WALDMAN: Yes.
So absolutely.
So the first question was about
Walt Whitman opposing democracy
and what exactly was his rationale.
And he wrote about, what he
said was the wolfish corruption
of politicians of the time.
And that he felt that this is what
happens when you let the masses
of the time vote them in.
And this goes, actually to the
second part of the question
which was what drove
the high participation.
We all know that in the late
1800s was a period not only
of considerable public
participation,
but also public corruption.
It was the time of Tammany
Hall in New York and Boss Tween
and you know all the, all the
legendary characters we know about.
And the reason that,
the question was
when was participation
at its height?
And when you look at
participation as a share,
in effect of who was legally allowed
to participate, it was probably
in 1800s when women couldn't vote,
when African-American men
and woman couldn't vote.
But among white men
it was very robust.
It was a time of much
greater party mobilization.
And these political parties
were emphatically participatory
institutions, they rested
their power on millions
of people being involved.
There was a festive aspect to it.
A public tribalism almost
that actually had a lot to do
with why people participate.
And I mentioned that
ironically, one of the things
that helps constrict this, which
I wouldn't want to reverse this,
but it's the secret ballot among
other things made it less likely
that people would vote.
And it's a crazy thing, because
why would that be the case.
But think about if there were a
law passed saying you could root
for any football team you wanted,
but you had to do it in private.
And you couldn't tailgate
and so forth.
People might have sports
teams for which they rooted,
but it wouldn't be the same.
And in effect, we found when you
look at the level of mobilization
of the public as the strategy
in those days to win office,
versus the money drenched
system later,
it was much more participatory then.
So, what we have to come up
with is a way to not replicate,
but to draw on that spirit now.
And of course there are
many ways that people engage
with each other including
through digital communities
and other things.
And we even have seen in some
of the more successful political
organizing efforts in recent years,
the public nature of that.
Whether it's the mass
rallies that Trump
and Sanders have had this time,
or the canvassing operation
of the Obama Campaign.
A colleague of ours, Erick
Lou [assumed spelling],
has written quite a bit about
the need to bring back that sense
of public celebration
to our democracy.
Turns out it was really
quite important.
We don't want to replicate all
of it, but it was not only.
Some people said well maybe the
voter turnout rates were so high
because it was all
cemeteries voting.
But even when you factor that out.
At that time, it was said that
the signers of the Declaration
of Independence were still
voting in Pennsylvania.
But even if you factor that out,
there was actually a lot
more involvement back then.
Yes, sir.
>> My name is Charlie Sullivan,
and I direct the Prison
Reform Organization.
And of course prison voting is one
of the exciting things
going on today.
A few years back, there
were actually four states
that allowed prisons to vote.
Utah and Massachusetts
were together.
Today we have Maine and Vermont.
They did away with those
two states, the legislature,
whatever the governors who led this.
And to me it was in violation
of another issue which
is very exciting.
And we actually, the United States
actually ratified the covenant
on civil and political rights,
which says that voting
universal suffrage, the same.
That was actually ratified before
the decision by those two states.
It seems to me that, I
realized that is not supposed
to be implemented to
a certain extent.
But it is the law of
this country and to me
that should have been
challenged by someone.
Maybe if the Brennan
Center had been in existence
or whatever had challenged it maybe
those two states would not be able
to deny voting rights to prisoners.
>> MICHAEL WALDMAN:
So the question is
about voting rights for prisoners.
For people in prison.
And for example, international
human rights conventions
and the possible challenge to that
practice that those could present.
>> Right and if there
had been ratified
by the United States,
which it was ratified.
It was actually before
those two states decided,
but no one challenged it.
>> MICHAEL WALDMAN: Well, you know
I think that it's pretty unlikely
that courts would strike down
a practice in the United States
for an international
convention of that kind.
That's always on of
the controversies
with these conventions.
But it's also important to note,
the Branson Center actually
has brought these cases.
Felony disenfranchisement
has long roots.
And actually is it explicitly
authorized in the 14th amendment
to the Constitution where it says
states cannot restrict the right
to vote, except for somebody who's
committed a felony or rebellion.
So there is a long
constitutional provenance
to felony disenfranchisement.
However, the way the system
exists is unquestionably unfair,
far harsher than other
countries have it,
and with a very significant
racial impact.
A lot of these laws
are actually passed
or created the way they were
created during the Jim Crow Era.
And one of the positive developments
this happened, it's not so much
about voting by people in prison.
But what about the millions and
millions of our fellow Americans
who have been in prison,
or who have been part
of the criminal justice system.
People with past felony convictions.
And that's something where
there is a very encouraging
and cross ideological and
often bipartisan movement
to change our felony voting rules.
It's interest, it's something of
a byproduct of the coming together
of understanding around mass
incarceration in the United States.
As you know, both left and
right are quite active right now
in understanding as has been
frequently explained that we have 5%
of the world's population, and 25%
of the world's prison population.
And that is not necessary to
keep the cities and streets safe.
And that there's a tremendous
racial, and social and economic cost
to having a system like that.
There's also a cost
to our democracy.
And so over the last 10 or 15 years,
even though there have been
all these partisan fights
on voting going on over here,
there's been a wonderful movement
to end felony disenfranchisement
or make it easier for people
with past felony convictions,
people who are in the community,
they've served their
sentence, they're paying taxes,
they're doing the right
thing, to reintegrate
in the community and vote.
And there's been a lot of legal
changes all over the place.
We work with Chuck Colson
and Prison Ministries.
With Jack Kemp before
they both passed away,
major conservative and
evangelical leaders.
The Christian Conservative
Movement is very involved.
And as you know here
in Washington DC,
there's been quite a
bit of movement here.
In Maryland last year, the
legislature passed a law
that restored the right
to vote to 40,000 people
with past felony convictions.
The governor vetoed it,
but it was overridden.
And as you know, Governor McAuliffe
a few weeks ago issued an executive
action that has the
consequences of giving
up to 200,000 people the right
to restore their right to vote.
It's important to know we
believe what he did was legal
and constitutional.
He urged him to do it.
I think it will be upheld by
the courts, if it's challenged.
It's also the case that
he and his Republican
and Democratic predecessors
as governor have been
doing this bit by bit.
He was not, this was not
a bolt out of the blue.
He followed on the previous
governors of both parties.
The big state where
there's continuing to be,
there's two states
where there remains.
No, so there's three states
with a lifetime ban on voting
for anybody who's convicted
of a felony.
Even if they were 18 in a
nonviolent drug possession
or something like that.
Iowa, Kentucky and Florida.
In Kentucky, Rand Paul is
one of the great champions
for doing something about that.
Florida is very challenging.
There are millions of
people affected overtime
and there's a constant push,
perhaps to get a ballot initiative
for a Constitutional limit there,
but you need 60% of the vote
to pass a ballot initiative,
so it's tough.
But this is an area of
actually of optimism.
Yes?
>> Did you say that the states
that started doing
universal voter registration,
that it's through the DMV?
>> MICHAEL WALDMAN: That's
where they started it.
>> I mean, the government finds you
when you're 65 whether you
have a driver's license or not.
Why? I mean it's not like that's
more you know focusing on people
who have driver's licenses.
>> MICHAEL WALDMAN: Right,
and fewer, not only do about 1
in 10 eligible voters not have
a driver's license, but fewer
and fewer have a driver's license.
But younger people actually don't
want to get driver's licenses.
My three kids it's actually
been quite a challenge
to get them to go do it.
So, nobody wants to stop at the DMV,
but it greatly increases
the number of people.
Most people do go to the DMV and
are registered through there,
and it could be done through
social welfare agencies.
Selective Service.
All men when they turn 18, and as
of two weeks ago all women will now
register for the Selective Service.
And there is no reason that every
18-year-old eligible citizen can't
be registered.
You're exactly right.
The government has us on a list.
We're on plenty of lists.
They use those lists for all
different kinds of purposes.
And it ought to be made possible
for people to vote based on that.
>> Two more questions.
Great questions.
>> MICHAEL WALDMAN: Yes, ma'am.
[ Inaudible Audience Question ]
Seems to me, thank
you for your question.
It seems to me that there's two
broad issues that you raised.
One is, you know first of all,
even if we had no legal barriers
to participation, many
Americans just don't participate.
And there are a lot of reasons
for that, ranging from elections
that are not competitive, because
redistricting and other things
and they don't feel they
have a reason to participate,
to lack of public engagement in
a whole host of a different ways.
And so the answers, some of
it is on us, as citizens.
Some of it is making sure
that information is available
in a wide range, not just around
elections, or on election day.
In fact, the changes in technology
of how we communicate offer
some very positive potential
developments too.
You know we talked
about campaign finance,
which was the other
part of your question.
That's driven.
The massive increase in the
role of money in the last 30
or 40 years was driven mostly by
the need to buy 30 second TV ads
on publicly licensed
broadcast stations.
That was why.
And as we all know.
That is a less and less
important way of communicating
with the public, versus all
the other ways we communicate.
People who are now able
to access information
from candidates through
digital means.
Now that stuff's expensive too, but
it actually isn't close to being
as expensive as the 30 second
ad regime targeted at a sliver
of swing voters which is
what we've been living
through over the last
several decades.
That goes to the second part
of your question which was
about the new version of
public campaign finance.
So the idea of public
financing has always been
that it's a public function
running an election in a democracy
and if you can in effect replace
the private money in some way
that you can give candidates
a chance
to represent a broader
swath of the public.
And some of the earlier
versions of public financing,
including the version that was
quite successful for several decades
for presidential campaigns, although
it eventually was out of date.
The idea was that you give a big
block of money to the candidate
if they qualified, and
then they were done,
they wouldn't raise it anymore.
The new version actually
seeks to boost participation.
It doesn't try to get all the
private money out of politics.
It doesn't pretend you can try
to get all the private money out.
What it does is try
to boost the voices
of small donors, of ordinary people.
And the most successful
model in the country
so far is actually
used in New York City.
Small donors there get a 6
to 1 match from taxpayers.
And it hasn't changed everything,
but it's changed very much
who can run, who they listen to,
how they run their campaigns,
and the competitiveness
of campaigns.
You'll still have Michael
Bloomberg spending $100 million
at a pop, to win the mayoralty.
But other than him, who
was kind of an outlier,
it's actually been
tremendously widely used
and tremendously effective system
but I think it would make a big
difference if we could bring it
to Congress and the presidency.
Last question.
I'll be quick.
>> My question is actually
voting on election day.
Are there, I assume there are
rules and laws about hours
that polling places have to be open,
where they can be, access to people
in different communities.
I know in the primary there
was a big issue in Arizona,
where I guess they did use
the number of polling places.
So I'm just curious what the
state of play is around that
and are the states trying
to restrict that, or
sort of [inaudible].
>> MICHAEL WALDMAN: You
know, yes the answer is yes.
The question was about the
actual hours on election day,
are those subject to the
controversy and manipulation.
And the answer is yes.
We don't have a national
election in this country.
We don't even have state elections.
We have thousands of
counties running elections.
We have tried as a country
when we've been good at this
to set national standards
for what the bare minimum is.
That in effect was part of
what the Voting Rights Act was.
In Maricopa County, this year,
which previously had been covered
by Voting Rights Act and
no longer is by section 5.
A local official decided gee what
would happen if we closed 70%
of the polling places in the
heavy Hispanic Maricopa County,
and not surprisingly, people had
to wait hours and hours in line.
And that was not, even if it was
not malevolent, which we don't know,
it would have been stopped
by the Voting Rights Act.
There ought to be a national
standard for at the very least,
making sure there's enough voting
machines per person on election day,
and enough opportunities
for early voting.
There's a bipartisan commission
appointed by President Obama,
led by Ben Ginsberg, who was
Mitt Romney's chief counsel,
and Bob Bauer, who
was his chief counsel
that proposed national standards on
early voting, on voting machines,
and all this kind of stuff.
So, really good, it's the
right set of policies.
There actually could
be federal legislation.
There was a bill called the county
revote act about 10 years ago
that embodied a lot of this stuff.
And Hillary Clinton was the sponsor
and she's made clear in her campaign
that this something she would want
federal legislation on as well
as automatic, universal
registration.
The thing to remember is right now,
about 1 out of 3 people
don't vote on election day.
So the market, there's really
been customer service here
by election officials and states.
It's much more convenient in
this day and age for people
to vote early, or absentee,
or by mail, or whatever.
Some of us are unfortunate
enough to live
in places that don't have those.
And New York is backwards
on almost every front.
In North Carolina, the state
legislature passed a kind
of greatest hits voter suppression
bill that had every single bad idea,
all in one piece of legislation.
And it was challenged in court,
and last year there was a trial.
And North Carolina's defense was
they said as bad as we are now,
we're not as bad as New York.
We cut back on early voting.
New York doesn't have early voting.
We ended same day registration,
New York never had it
in the first place.
And on, and on.
So there are wide variations,
but there's an inexorable consumer
demand for ways to vote other
than standing online on
election day and I'm sure
that will continue to be the case.
>> JOHN COLE: Michael
thank you very much.
>> MICHAEL WALDMAN: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> JOHN COLE: He's done it again.
You get a wonderful civics lesson
when you get a book
talk from Michael.
That happened with the first book.
It happened again today.
I want to thank him very
much for the presentation.
His patience, your patience and
have a chance to speak with him
at the book signing in the back.
The books are for sale
at the Library
of Congress employee discount
10% take advantage of that.
And have another, have
an opportunity
to get his signature as well.
Thanks for joining us.
One more round of applause
for Michael Waldman.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.